So now it's time for us to put all of our building blocks together
and we're just this close to showing that
SAT is indeed NP complete.
So we started out with a problem in NP
and input fallout problem; of course, this here can be any problem in NP
and this here can be any input fallout problem
and what do we then do?
We said if the problem is in NP,
then there must be some algorithm for that problem
which runs in polynomial time on a non deterministic RAM,
so an algorithm or a program
you can call it any way you want,
so that will run in polynomial time,
and the algorithm at some lines of the code
either says yes or says no,
but it's running in polynomial time in any case,
and of course the input for the problem,
well that is basically just the number of variables
in the memory of the machine as it starts out.
Then we took all this and of course it's a huge Boolean formula
and you would probably never really want to write it out explicitly,
but it exists and it contains a number of components that we have discussed.
So one part of the Boolean formula encodes snapshots
of the algorithm as it runs on the machine.
Then we said we have to have 1 part that ensures that
the first snapshot properly represents the starting conditions
so that it properly the algorithm starting at line one
and also the memory representing the input for the problem.
Then what we just discussed is that
through a number of rules that look like if-then,
you can ensure that the snapshot is at a certain point in time t
and at the following time point fit together,
and then finally,
since this here is a decision problem,
we want to ensure that the Boolean formula
can only be satisfied
if at certain point in time
the algorithm returns yes,
so this is the last part we have to add to the Boolean formula,
and this is actually quite easy to ensure,
because once the algorithm reaches this line of the code,
wherever it may be, and you can even have multiple lines
where the algorithm returns yes,
but once such line has been reached,
the algorithm returns yes and stops,
so this her is very easy to ensure.
You just have to make sure that there's one snapshot
where the algorithm is in a line that returns a yes.
So once we have constructed this Boolean formula,
what happens if we solve SAT for this formula?
Then there's 2 cases that can happen,
because SAT is also a decision problem,
so either SAT returns yes
or it returns no.
What if it returns yes?
If it returns yes, that means that there is a satisfying assignment
for this Boolean formula, and a satisfying assignment
will have the following property.
First of all, it will encode valid snapshots
of where the algorithm is
and whats in the memory.
Secondly, it will also ensure that the machine starts out
in the right place,
meaning it starts out at line 1 of the code
and representing the input for the problem,
it will ensure that all the snapshots
that it has figured out will fit together
and it can only return yes
if the algorithm returns yes at some point in time.
So if we have a yes here,
we also know that this problem or the decision problem here
is one where a non deterministic RAM would also answer yes.
If it says no, on the other hand,
what does that mean?
Well, we know that we always can encode the snapshots,
so it's not going to say no, because it can not encode a snapshot,
because that's possible always.
It also won't say no due to this property here,
because well, we have ensured
that the snapshot can properly encoded,
so there's no mistake in the formula here, so it can not say no because of this here.
It also can not say no because of this here,
because the machine will always run
and you can make the snapshots fit together.
The only reason why there can be no satisfying assignment
is if the algorithm does not return yes at a certain point in time
and since this algorithm solve this problem here,
if it can not reach yes,
then this means that this decision problem here
is also a no.
So satisfiability
only if this problem given this input here
is a yes.
So now that we have put it together,
here's our final quiz for proving that SAT is NP complete,
and what I would like you to do is to recap
the properties of this Boolean formula here.
First of all, what is the size of this Boolean formula
for an input of size n
and remember this algorithm here
runs in polynomial time.
So is this Boolean formula up here
constant in size,
polynomial in size, or exponential in size
with respect to n?
and then can this Boolean formula encode
any algorithm at least for a problem that is an NP?
Can it encode any input of size n that were given to that problem?
Finally is this Boolean formula satisfiable if
the input here is a yes
to not decision problem here
or are there any other cases where
we could also have satisfiabilty.
So please check all of these that are true.